Hello and welcome to this course on
AI Systems Introduction to Navigation.
We'll be doing this course in Unreal Engine version 5.5.
However, most of this
hasn't changed for quite a few versions of the engine,
so you should be okay working in
previous engine versions I think all the way through five.
Now in this, we're going to go over
a number of different things.
We're going to go over how to
set up navigation and something called a NavMesh.
We're going to look at methods of customizing it so that we
can make the behavior
respond to the environment that we've created.
We're also going to have a go at making it dynamic
so that it changes at runtime
without having too much of a cost.
Finally, we're going to look at
different methods of getting the AI to avoid each other,
so they don't all get clumped up.
The first question, what is a NavMesh?
Well, a NavMesh or more common full name of
a navigation mesh is
a simplified map of the walkable areas used in game.
What it is, is it is a map which is generated and
created and modifiers are added to it,
and it is laid over the world.
Its primary function is just so that we can
figure out a path of how to get from one place to another.
It shows us what the walkable areas are.
This is a standard method,
it pre-calculates pathfinding,
allowing the AI to navigate complex environments efficiently.
All that means is it will break down all of the environment into
blocks and calculate the distance
that will be required to move across them.
Therefore, rather than actually having
to analyze the environment every single time that it goes in,
we just need to run an algorithm against
the table generated blocks and it'll tell us
the most efficient way to move through the environment.
Now, it's not entirely realistic.
Take for example, we had a maze.
Using this method, the AI is going to know
the exact best most efficient path to get through that maze,
to navigate it, where a natural AI would probably get lost
and would end up having to explore to find its way through it.
But a NavMesh is always going to give us
the most efficient best path.
Now, if you want to see some working examples
of a NavMesh in AI movement setup,
I can recommend two different projects to you.
The first one is the Lyra example game.
This is a fully implemented AAA game,
set up so that you can explore and see how everything is created.
In this, we do rely on the AI,
so you can see the AI set up there.
Secondly, we have something called the Matrix City demo.
Now, this is a massive open-world city,
which has hundreds and hundreds of
different AIs wandering around it with logic built-in.
Now, this also uses our mass crowd system to do avoidance.
So this is a good example of that setup.
For this project, when we get into it,
we do not require you to download a project for this.
We are going to be using the top-down template,
which can be found under the game section.
We'll be using that to do all of our examples.
So I recommend that you follow along with this.
I recommend that you open up that top-down template,
create a new project for that,
and we'll be able to follow
along with everything that we're doing.
Thank you very much.
In the next videos, we will jump into the browser.